well you guys know by now that I'm a
firm believer in what the Bible says
that the borrower is slave to the lender
because your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income and when
you haven't committed your income in the
form of payments to everybody else you
can invest it and become wealthy really
the average car payment in America today
is 503 dollars that's just pray that's
nutty if you invest $500 in a decent
growth stock mutual fund from age 30 to
age 70 you'll have over five million
dollars that one thing to make you worth
five million dollars and now the blended
car payments are staying out of them
isn't that amazing
and so I've become known for getting
people out of debt and the only reason I
get people out of debt is because it
increases their generosity and increases
their ability to invest and become
wealthy which also increases our
generosity and it changes your life it
changes your family tree it changes your
retirement you retire with dignity you
don't have to buy that cookbook 72 ways
to prepare Alpo and love it
you can retire with dignity but you have
to do it on purpose and getting out of
debt in order to invest as a shortest
way and what is amazing to me is that
the almost the entire financial industry
focuses on one part of the equation and
that's the investing part of the
equation and they all have a bunch of
theories now I've had all the letters
and licenses after my name I have a
degree in finance I've had all the
licenses in the business dropped all of
them because I didn't want to be
regulated what I could say here on the
air
the only license I still have active my
real estate license I've had it since I
was 18 and they don't regulate much so
I'm I'm going to keep that one but you
know the rest of it is just it is
amazing the number of people in the
financial world whether they're
financial advisers writers bloggers
whatever they do that have opinions of
money that don't have any money and
whose track record on teaching people to
invest in getting them to invest sucks
3% of the public is where all of those
people make their money off wealthy
people they make all their money off
wealthy people and most of the advisers
out there won't fool with you if you
don't have some money they don't want to
sit down talk to you and so we start
teaching people of course all these
years ago how we invest and then as
we've met with many many many thousands
of millionaires over the years how did
they invest what are they doing
well we suggest and I personally invest
in good growth stock mutual funds I
spread it across four types growth and
income growth aggressive growth and
international and I buy mutual funds
that have at least a 10-year track
record I'll Dave shouldn't you just buy
index funds well you can if you want
index funds basically an S&P 500 fund
mirrors the market that basically is the
stock market and so you're going to do
exactly what the stock market does good
or bad the mutual funds that I buy I'll
perform the S&P 500 and they're really
not that hard to find a lot of mutual
funds don't outperform this and P 500 so
if you're going to buy that well that'd
be dumb just buy an S&P 500 but I buy
mutual funds that outperform this and P
500 and my portfolio mix that I just
outlined is pretty much always beats
that market because I bought funds that
outperform the market it's you know not
that hard to do you open up the
prospectus and there's two little lines
on the graph one of them is the S&P 500
if the mutual fund you're looking at if
that line is below that S&P 500 line
don't buy that fun does this is hard
really not that much to this but Dave
you you just tell people by those loaded
funds yeah a commission that's fine have
somebody in your life helping you do the
investing all the data says that you'll
continue to invest doing that but when
you jump when you're you know out there
by yourself with all your theories and
they you know
some idiot newscaster comes on the
evening news predicting the end of the
world what do you do you cash out all
your mutual funds at exactly the wrong
time because you don't have anybody in
your corner saying don't jump don't dupe
instead you're just out there with your
own emotions in the newscaster and
that's how you pick out your when you
jump in or out of the market and that's
just dumb
so all the data says a decent portfolio
of good performing mutual funds wins and
the big thing is actually putting money
into the mutual funds actually investing
one piece of research shows that 74% of
the reason of retirement success is
doing it
it's called savings rate a number of you
that put money in versus talk about it
and continually put money in year after
year year after year year after year
month after month week after week out of
your check into your 401 K over and over
and over and over and over again this
how you get wealthy you do not get
wealthy by saving on fees because fees
don't keep you from getting wealthy it's
ludicrous these are theories promoted by
people who don't do anything and most of
them don't have any money so I'm a
multi-millionaire and I pay mutual fund
fees to my broker boom just like that
you hear that and you know why because I
need a broker in my life I need somebody
that's an advisor I know a lot about
mutual funds but I don't pick my own I
let them pick out four or five I'm not
going through 8,000 mutual funds I have
what's known as a life I'm going to
actually have you know pick out three or
four dude I'm going to sit down with you
we're going to look at them I'm going to
pick out that takes me about 30 seconds
and let me tell you I pick mutual funds
about 80% of the choice on my mutual
fund 85% is based on its rate of return
it's a track record I look if the track
record is tied and I'm trying to look I
look for the longest track record who's
been doing it a long time I like
neighborhoods with big oak trees when
I'm buying real estate see what I'm
saying I like a long track record
something stable I don't
risk I like to make money risk equals
not making money for me big risk anyway
and I you know I pay the fee I'll look
at the fees and see if the fees are
unusually high and I might pick a fund
if everything else is equal has a lower
fee but I'm not so you know some people
are stepping over $5 bills trying to
pick up pennies worrying about these
fees you know I've seen 57 dollars out
of a thousand whew you're getting rich
you know that's not what's getting
arrested it's the fact that the fund is
invested in something that's going up in
value and you do it over and over and
over and over again and don't jump in
and out of the market based on what's
going on it's going down I'm scared it's
going up I'm hot I'm greedy
you know that's called chasing returns
this is the best way to lose your butt
you know get in there and just stay in
there and just ride it and ride it and
ride it
we're going to talk about these four
types of mutual funds a little bit more
when we come back thank you for joining
us America this is the Dave Ramsey show
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money
we're talking about mutual funds and how
to invest to become wealthy we should
spread it across four types growth and
income growth aggressive growth and
international well let's talk about
those for a second because there's all
kinds of names for mutual funds and the
name of the mutual fund tells you what
is in the fund okay a growth and income
fund is also called a large cap fund are
sometimes also called a blue chip fund
the blue chip is the most expensive chip
on the poker table so that means these
are big companies in this large cap is
short for large capitalization large
capitalization means these are large
companies and so your growth and income
funds are large companies
boring of the four types of mutual funds
that I put money into and I recommend
this is the calmest if you were to chart
this volatility on this fund versus the
stock market you would see it's a lot
calmer than the market and so it's your
friend when things are going down in
other words it's your stable it's the
big old dinosaur companies they're
boring when things are going up by the
way it's also boring it's not exciting
when things are going up it's a downer
you look at that thing going why is it
not doing well when the rest of the
market is going up because it goes
slower than the market up and slower
than the market down because it's a
stable and stable land a growth fund is
right in the middle the SP 500 index
fund would be considered a growth fund a
growth fund is companies that are
growing they're kind of medium-sized
company so you might call it here at
call mid cap fund and so you know these
are just standard growth stock mutual
funds there's a whole lot of these out
there ton of funds that fall in this
area so the idea is pretty simple the
growth fund you know that's kind of
right there in the middle you want
something in the middle and it's pretty
much going to do about what the market
does in terms of volatility but you can
get mutual funds that are growth stock
mutual funds that outperform the S&P 500
you can even get growth and income funds
even though they're not as volatile but
outperform the S&P 500
then there's the aggressive Growth Fund
this is the wild brother okay it's the
crazy one and so you might guess it's
going to be also called a small cap
funds these are the small companies the
startups a lot of tech companies would
fall into they're very crazy all the fun
weird stuff is in there and that means
some of it fails and goes to zero and so
it's a crazier mix it's going to be much
more volatile than the stock market is
so it's going to go up faster than the
market goes up but it's going to go down
faster than the market goes down
small-cap aggressive growth stock mutual
funds also known in there as I'm a small
cap aggressive emerging market you would
call it that too as well
international funds means that the
stocks in it are our overseas companies
they're not American companies it has a
kissing cousin called a global fund if
you think of a globe what is it it's
everything so that would have
international and US companies in a
global fund and it would be a cousin to
a an international by the way American
companies generally outperform other
international companies and by and large
as a group and so your international
fund will be your worst performing of
the four over the last several decades
and a global fund will outperform an
international fund because you put some
spice in there you put some American
companies in there usually and so
they're a little bit better but at least
you got some stuff overseas you're not a
hundred percent betting on the American
economy
not that I'm anti-american I am NOT this
is not a patriotic thing this is a
diversification thing and so you know
you want to have some BMW and some
Mercedes in there you want to have some
LG and some other stuff even though some
of those things are made stateside those
are foreign companies and so you look
for you know companies that are overseas
base could be a French company could be
whatever and that are in an
international fund and then you spread
your investing across those four types
and so I'm you know very simple here
very simple the thing is do it that's
the thing everybody talks and talks and
talks and talks and talks about
investing the problem is nobody does it
people we talk to on the millionaire
theme hour that are millionaires you
know they got to be millionaires they
did it and they never want to ask them
how they became millionaires they never
say oh man I hit the homerun I got this
mutual fund had low fees they never say
that
because it never happens all day if I
hit the homerun I got this mutual fund
that went was straight up and I made all
my money and won one goodbye you know my
golfing buddy gave me a Scott stock tip
I don't meet millionaires that are did
that I hear stories about it but a
golfing buddy with a stock tip is like a
golfing buddy with a fishing story the
one that got away I mean it's just
everybody's got an opinion and it's all
a bunch of crap and so you just have to
really stop and go slow and steady
actually investing is the way it's the
way it's the only way to go it's the
only way to go so growth and income
growth aggressive growth international
don't chase the returns do not invest
money in things you do not understand
people get ripped off when they invest
money in things that someone told them
is good and they trusted the person
instead of knowing what the flip they
were doing you know all these athletes
you read about NFL stars and they lost
ten million dollars or they made made a
hundred million dollars and it's all
gone and you know you know how they lose
their money
because they give it to someone else to
handle and they don't even look at it
and then they're shocked to find out
that person was a crook that's how you
lose your money it's your money it's
like it's your kids which means you have
to make it behave there's like you have
to make your kids behave you have to do
that if you want good kids that's how
it's going to happen if you want money
that's how it's going to happen
you have to understand it now you don't
have to have a master's degree in
finance this stuff is not rocket science
it is really not that difficult and you
really really seriously have to do this
and you have to understand what the
money is going into do not put money in
that's why when you're buying insurance
when you're getting a mortgage when you
are doing your investing in mutual funds
that's why when you do all of that that
you have to
understand what you're doing the only
way you're going to do that is when
you're picking someone to help you in
one of those areas you're doing your
estate plan if it's complicated you're
doing your taxes if they're complicated
that kind of thing you need someone
sitting on the other side of the table
that is not a salesperson but that is
they may be selling they may make a
commission but they have the heart of a
teacher not the heart of a salesperson
and so they're selling not by twisting
your arm or getting you to buy something
you don't understand instead they sell
by getting you to understand what you're
doing and then you choose to do it I'm
an easy sale once I understand something
but until I understand it I'm not
putting a dime in it I'm not going
forward with this it's that simple
so don't put money in things you don't
understand always use an investment
professional that has the heart of a
teacher don't be afraid to pay some
commissions you don't want to overpay
but that's not the end of the world the
big deal here is pick out some mutual
funds if you're investing going and do
it every month if you need some help
check our smart investor pros click
smart investor at Dave Ramsey comm and
you can find a list of the people we
endorse in your area they don't work for
me but I endorse them and they have the
heart of a teacher and they'll help you
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]